un énorme clash entre Kevin Virginie et
Caroline c'est un des plus gros clashs
de l'histoire de la télévision et de
Secret Story heureusement qu'il y avait
une vitre regardez
[Musique]
heureusement il y a une vitre
alors moi je suis venu pour te dire deux
choses
ah oui d'abord je vais parler parce que
la première fois tu as parlé et j'ai pas
pu ouvrir ma gueule alors j'ai une seule
chose à vous dire à tous les deux je
l'avais demandé une seule chose Kevin
une seule c'était de pas venir ici avec
elle c'était une seule chose vous avez
décidé de vous remettre ensemble tant
mieux pour vous je te souhaite
absolument tout le bonheur que tu
mérites avec lui mais c'est au plus
sincère de mon cœur tu as voulu prendre
les miettes prends les miettes tu as
attendu pendant 3 ans j'en ai tu te tais
tu me laisses parler
tu comprends ça vous êtes venus tous les
deux ici pour faire quoi pour vous
appuyer vous vendez pas assez de papier
dehors
il y a un autre clash culte dans Secret
Story celui de Mélanie Anaïs lors de la
saison 10 la prod n'a pas eu le temps de
réagir tellement Anaïs était
imprévisible regardez ça et Jean-Michel
vous n'y croyez pas vous allez nous dire
pourquoi dans un instant regarde
c'est pour ça que j'ai
pas tu viens tu me parles normal et
après par derrière tu me casses que tu
vas me rendre dans le cul dans le cul tu
vas voir
je te jure je me retiens là bah retiens
toi
en fait toi la pierre dans le cou c'est
pas possible
correctement au moins d'accord
et mets-toi de ce qui te regarde
[Applaudissements]
non moi j'y crois pas trop parce que je
crois qu'on est arrivé à la fin de ce
genre de mission d'enfermement comme ça
voilà on a besoin on a besoin d'autres
choses là franchement on a fait le tour
un peu de du sujet après il y a eu les
Marseillais tout ça ça renouvelé un peu
d'être à l'extérieur
je pense c'est moins bien les
Marseillais qu'au contraire tous les
gens qui vont regarder les Marseillais
ils ont pas vu ces émissions avant
je pense que ça va être nouveau pour eux
qu'au contraire moi ça va ça va
cartonner à la télé pas sur une
plateforme
matin
[Musique]
story apparemment c'est love story qui
tiendrait voilà la la corde et puis Love
Story c'est quand même le format multi
on a fait le top 3 des plus grosses
d'arcade de Secret Story après vous
allez redonner votre avis surtout
Raymond qui est tout émoustillé en 3e
position des rigolades de Secret Story
on a Mélanie Da Cruz et sa pizza viande
hachée regardez je suis en train de cuis
finir le plat dahlia pendant qu'il y en
a qui mangent d'accord mais après qu'on
me laisse pas bouffer bah tu sais quoi
classe c'est qui qui l'a préparé la
pizza 4 ans de cuire tu es malade ou
quoi j'ai de la pizza viande hachée je
vais me taper de la pizza je sais pas
quoi j'ai même pas faim voilà je voulais
de la pizza viande hachée ou manger
qu'est-ce que tu veux faire mais je ne
veux pas de pizza blanc de poulet vous
comprenez j'ai droit de manger ce que je
veux ou pas
[Musique]
en numéro 2 on a Sabrina de la saison 7
qui a des petites difficultés avec la
langue française
non pas avec le pied car le pied de la
fourchette par le biais
mais non
voilà tous l'expression de nos pieds
bonheur
ça c'était extraordinaire tu peux tu
l'écris tu le mets pas Raymond tu crois
toi le numéro vous allez voir le plus
gros comme Valérie Benjamin sur la
plateforme il faut leur laisser la
liberté en fait on peut on peut plus
maintenant faire un truc à la télé dès
que tu dis un truc c'est censuré il y a
l'arcom il y a les pistes froids qui
vont mettre des tweets ça va tu peux
plus rien faire tu peux plus rien faire
donc sur une plateforme si vous voulez
laisser faire et ce qui a dit
qu'améliards c'était pas con de pas
mettre des cadres heures pas mettre des
gens qui viennent il faut que ce soit
des caméras automatiques il faut les
laisser faire c'est la base bah il faut
les laisser faire j'y crois sur une
plateforme et ça ça peut être vachement
bien mais si parce que ça peut être bien
comme indici Cindy le casting très
important prenez pas des gens qui vont
être là pour être connus sur Instagram
et vendre des savons ou de l'eau du bain
après derrière faut prendre des gens il
faut qu'ils viennent là pour être des
vrais gens des gens de la vie de tous
les jours vous prenez des pages c'est un
peu rubikaran ne n'écoute pas les autres
on va voir en première position alors
c'était Rachel le grain Trapani oublier
qu'elle a été secret
le plus court de l'histoire
alors je vous rappelle que je vous
rappelle que que
Rachel Miss France 2007 et qu'elle doit
dissimuler les autres évidemment ça
c'est limité son titre et ce n'est pas
une candidate c'est c'est que pour le
fun et pour la blague mais pour
l'instant personne ne l'a reconnu en
même temps faut dire qu'on
a pas reconnaissance
c'est que le secret il a fait long feu
hein
c'est le secret le plus ripple de
l'histoire de France non mais vraiment
si jamais vu un secret aussi répondu
c'est incroyable ça Castaldi toi tu
crois alors ah oui sur les réseaux
absolument parce qu'on avait un vrai
problème sur secret c'était que TF1 il y
a les hanches dans le nez et qu'on était
voilà on était toujours sur le coup de
la de la censure il fallait on avait une
angoisse et qu'on est à moins de 12
parce que sinon on passait de 19h à 22h
donc si on est libre dans ce programme
ils pourront aller très loin et dans les
secrets dans le casting tu as raison
faut des gens normaux parce qu'on en
peut plus des des caricatures et là je
vois même même les classes aujourd'hui
les budding je sais pas dire en anglais
[Rires]
les gens normaux n'y ont plus dans ce
genre de genre d'émission il y avait une
fraîcheur dans les deux trois premières
années mais moi j'y crois pas mais je
dis pas que tu as un secret à nous
révéler toi Cindy
non j'ai pas de secret mais pour
rejoindre ce que dit Madame alors c'est
Madame comment oui c'est Madame
pourquoi
l'amour est dans le pré cartonne parce
que ce sont des gens exactement donc un
moment donné on va voir du vrai du
normal pas des gens refait de partout on
les reconnaît même plus ils sont tous
pareils toi si tu devais t'enfermer
toute seule dans une maison pendant une
semaine j'attends la chute avec non non
tu serais ce serait plutôt avec Raymond
bah arrêtez ou avec Jean-Michel
avec un samedi
quoi finalement avec Castaldi ah oui oui
je vais le pourrir pendant une semaine
tu penses qu'il pourrait se passer
quelque chose si tu enfermé avec lui
pendant une semaine je ne dirai je ne
sais pas à moi
aussi parce qu'elle est importante
autant embêté Castaldi quoi
vous voulez que je me fasse des ennemis
j'aime tous les deux toi tu aimes bien
tout le monde toi en fait
que Jean-Michel c'est moi ton genre que
Castany
[Rires]
tu vas faire un classe oui
il est au top du top
on se connaît